[Musique]
si vous êtes passionné d'animation
japonaise et de pop culture vous ferez
certainement un tour à manga story dans
cette boutique on peut trouver des
produits dérivés mais aussi des posters
ou des mangas enzo le garn bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le co gérant de cette
boutique alors la boutique est ouverte
il y à peu près quatre mois est ce que
les amateurs de mangas sont au rendez
vous alors oui oui sont ils sont au
rendez vous ils sont très contents
d'avoir un lieu comme comme tel proche
de chez eux
du coup il y est au rendez vous depuis
maintenant way depuis maintenant quatre
mois sont très contents est-ce que les
versailles et son sont amateurs de
mangas pourquoi avoir finalement créé
cette boutique dans versailles
tout simplement parce que c'est quand
même versailles c'est quand même une
ville importante de la région avec le
château juste en face du coup et puis
même verfeil c'est pas forcément proche
de paris a quand même pas mal de temps
au transport du coup c'est quand même
l'occasion de que les habitants du
secteur puissent avoir un lieu comme tel
pouvoir se retrouver acheter des
produits de série qu'ils aiment vous
avez beaucoup de produits dérivés
ce que vous pouvez me dire combien vous
en avez à peu près quelles sont les
catégories de produits
alors pour les catégories on va avoir un
peu tôt avoir des figurines des peluches
des posters et des mugs entre autres
mais on a pas mal de choses aussi pour
plus spécialisés comme des maquettes et
mac et des petites constructions on a
des coffrets cadeaux vraiment du tout en
rapport avec avec les mangas c'est
vraiment un peu un peu tout et d'armes
de référence on devra avoir je pense
2000 références différentes
c'est pas mal vos produits stars que
vous vendez le plus finalement après le
généralement les produits qui vont le
plus attiré l'oeil de nos clients ça va
être les mangas et les figurines du cou
qui représentent leurs personnages
favoris de chaque série
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous pouvez peut-être me
présenter un beau coup de coeur alors
oui bien sûr alors moi c'est comme comme
produit que personne particulièrement ça
va être ce projet là c'est une figurine
représentant le chic et le héros de du
manga one piece qui est le manga le plus
populaire au monde c'est le manga le
plus vendu au monde depuis maintenant
quelques années
donc voilà think green qui représente le
héros sous différentes
il ya de nombreuses boutiques de manga
qui maintenant se développe un peu à
votre avis qu'est ce qui fait que la
culture manga est de plus en plus
apprécié et populaire en france
finalement mort parce qu'elle est de
plus en plus accessible maintenant pour
pour tout le monde avec les plateformes
de streaming pour les animer les mangas
du coup maintenant les rayon librairie
de chaque boutique se développe à la
fnac y en a de plus en plus partout en
fait dans partout film avec netflix
car maintenant alors je catalogue
d'animer du coup c'est beaucoup plus
accessible pour les plus jeunes comme
pour les plus vieux est juste et voir
quel type de public qui vient dans votre
nettement on a un peu de tout on va
avoir une idée plus jeune ça peut
commencer à 4 5 ans pour des peluches ou
des jouets com de com des des pères des
mères de famille de 40 ans qui
souhaitent avoir des produits
représentant leurs personnages de leur
enfance pour le côté un peu nostalgique
part est ce qu'il y a aussi des mangas
ou des des séries dans la guerre
allemands qui sont un peu tendance en ce
moment alors oui alors on va avoir déjà
les grands indémodable et grands
classiques qui sont qui resteront
toujours au goût du jour qui sont one
piece dragon ball ou encore naruto mais
il est vrai qu'il ya d'autres séries qui
sont en train de vraiment d'émerger même
mondialement comme actuellement la
taille des tic en damon slayer et le
dernier petit nouveau qui est vraiment
en train d'exploser cdu dit ce qu'elle
sait très bien les bains merci beaucoup
aidé les gammes d'avoir été notre invité
c'est moi qui vous remercie
[Musique]